Despite "Barbie" being nominated for
Best Picture for the 2024 Academy Awards,
Margot Robbie wasn't nominated for Best Leading
Actress, and Greta Gerwig was shut out of Best
Director category. In the end, these snubs are
dispiriting, but utterly unsurprising. Here's why.
Year after year, the Best Picture race is
predominantly occupied by movies helmed by
men — white men, more often than not — with only a
few women breaking through to secure a nomination.
It's important to note that, in
the Academy's 95-year history,
only three women have ever won the top prize:
Kathryn Bigelow for "The Hurt Locker" in 2009,
Chloé Zhao for "Nomadland" in 2021, and Jane
Campion for "The Power of the Dog" in 2022.
It's also important to say that,
at the upcoming 96th Oscars,
French director Justine Triet is the sole woman
recognized in the category, and last year,
zero female directors were nominated.
This is an obvious and systemic issue!
Greta Gerwig is actually a pretty fascinating
example of a woman who frequently receives
half-hearted, seemingly insincere honors from
the Academy without actual, tangible recognition.
Yes, she was nominated for directing "Lady
Bird," but she lost to Guillermo del Toro
for "The Shape of Water" and was up against only
men. Her sophomore effort, "Little Women," scored
a Best Picture nod and ignored Gerwig's
considerable work from behind the camera.
Now, with "Barbie," Gerwig has been shut
out for her third critically acclaimed
film. The snub is egregious, but it's
also par for the course at this point.
"Everything's almost, like, reversed here."
Margot Robbie is technically an Oscar nominee at
the 96th Academy Awards — but not for her
performance in "Barbie." As a producer,
she earned a nomination for its
inclusion in the Best Picture category.
This is, at face value, pretty shocking ...
especially when you consider that Robbie was,
perhaps, edged out by Carey Mulligan
in Bradley Cooper's biopic "Maestro",
which was met with mixed reviews.
Robbie does something fairly spectacular in
"Barbie," considering that she transforms
America's most famous doll into a
fully realized character. Robbie's
vision of Barbie — aided in no small part
by Greta Gerwig's excellent yet unrecognized
direction and the script she co-wrote with
her partner Noah Baumbach — takes her on a
journey that transforms her into a real
person, someone desperate to become the
one who imagines instead of being simply an
idea. In doing all of this, Robbie commits
one of the biggest sins possible in the eyes
of the Motion Picture Academy — she's funny.
"I don't have anything big planned,
just a giant, blow-out party with
all the Barbies and planned choreography
and a bespoke song. You should stop by!"
Comedy is so consistently overlooked at
the Oscars that when Marisa Tomei won for
her pitch-perfect performance
in "My Cousin Vinny" in 1992,
rumors swirled for years that presenter
Jack Palance read the wrong name.
Robbie's portrayal is heartfelt, emotional, and
compelling, but she also goes for broad comedy,
showing off the full range of her acting ability
by combining pratfalls with tearful admissions.
"I'm not used to that having anything in it!"
The Oscars rarely, if ever, reward comedy,
likely because it's not viewed as "serious"
art compared to biopics or movies that
make people feel completely depressed.
Robbie's performance being ignored is yet
another example of that irritating trend.
Those excusing "Barbie's" egregious omissions
in Best Director and Leading Actress might
point to the fact that the movie broke multiple
box-office records and made Greta Gerwig the
first female director to single-handedly helm
a movie that crossed the billion-dollar mark.
All of these accomplishments may have hurt
its full Oscar potential in the end, though.
Blockbusters, like comedies, were staunchly
ignored by the Academy for most of its
history — until outcry over Christopher Nolan's
universally adored Batman take, "The Dark Knight,"
won a posthumous acting award for Heath Ledger
without managing a Best Picture nomination.
From 2010 on, the Best Picture category expanded
to ten potential winners, usually tossing a
blockbuster into the fray to appease fans and
draw a bigger audience for the telecast. Movies
like "Black Panther," "Top Gun: Maverick,"
and "Mad Max: Fury Road," just to name a few,
were never going to win Best Picture, but were
nominated to keep complaints to a minimum.
"Barbie's" billion-dollar box-office haul
has relegated it to the "token blockbuster"
role this year. This is made particularly obvious
considering that it's nominated
alongside several smaller films.
"Oppenheimer" was also a high-grossing
cinematic juggernaut in 2023,
but unlike "Barbie," "Oppenheimer" is
more likely to be regarded as "serious"
because it's a historical biopic
about the creation of the atomic
bomb ... while "Barbie" apparently loses
artistic merit with each dollar it makes.
"Barbie" ended up with Best Picture and
Best Adapted Screenplay nominations,
but it also scored two acting nods in the
supporting categories. America Ferrera,
who plays Mattel employee Gloria and
delivers the film's most memorable monologue,
earned her first-ever Oscar nomination
for supporting actress. Unsurprisingly,
Ryan Gosling ended up with a nomination
for supporting actor — which is a problem.
Gosling's performance is, to be fair, truly
excellent. He shines in every single second of
the film, committing to his role as the hapless,
horse-obsessed Ken with the utmost passion.
"Horses are just men extenders."
"Ohhhh."
His "dream ballet," set to the
Oscar-nominated original song
"I'm Just Ken," is certainly one
of the movie's standout moments.
That said, it's a bit on the nose to
nominate Gosling and not Margot Robbie,
considering that one of the film's main conflicts
is that Ken overthrows the matriarchy of Barbie
Land to install a patriarchy and become
the society's "main character," of sorts.
Nominating the only standout male character
from a movie about the female experience — and
not the film's lead — is, frankly, insulting,
as are the other major "Barbie" nominations.
Unless it pulls a full "Argo," its
chances of winning Best Picture are
utterly insignificant without Greta
Gerwig in the Best Director category.
Its screenplay nod feels like the
Academy giving a small consolation
prize to a movie that feels too weird
or "unworthy" to win the big prize.
Ultimately, "Barbie" being overlooked
in majorly important categories isn't
all that shocking ... but it
does continue a disturbing,
unsettling trend of not taking movies seriously
if they're too funny, feminine, or fantastical.